uh thank you everyone for coming to the
second
frankie lecture of the fall term
uh
just a very brief introductory remarks
about the frankie lectures barbara and
rich
frankie have generously made this series
possible
it is a series designed to appeal to a
wide and general yale audience
addressing topics about the relation
between the humanities and the sciences
about different kinds of knowledge
different approaches to epistemology
relations between literature and science
and not just that but many other things
so we're very grateful to uh
barbara rich frankie for that generosity
and that thoughtfulness uh and that's
why we're here so welcome everyone to
the second uh lecture for uh the
franklin seminar for this fall term
today we are honored and delighted to
have ross posnock who is anna garbedian
professor of the humanities
at columbia university
professor posnock's
books include henry james and the
problem of robert browning
then after that the trial of curiosity
henry james william james in the
challenge of modernity that was from
oxford in 1991
that book is generally thought to be the
single best work out there on the
brothers james and if you're interested
in the relation between henry and
william you should look at ross's book
the trial of curiosity it's an excellent
book he's also the author of color and
culture black writers in the making of
the modern intellectual from harvard
in 1998 and most recently the author of
philip roth's rude truth the art of
immaturity that's from princeton 2006.
uh
the title's root truth may
echo for some of you a line from
emerson's self-reliance i ought to walk
upright and vital and speak the rude
truth
in all ways am i writing this yeah
that's right okay okay so um
that's an appropriate the emersonian
echo in the title of one of the else's
books uh pete ross is also the editor of
the cambridge companion to ralph waldo
ellison
editor 2005
and he also edits the series cambridge
studies in american literature and
culture
he is on the editorial board of guerrero
tan and american literary history
in 1994 uh professor posner was awarded
the guggenheim fellowship and in 2009 he
was elected to the american academy of
arts and sciences
he is also a regular contributor of
essays and reviews generation
and the new republic
uh puzzle is currently at work on a book
about writers
artists and philosophers who
re-enunciate or renounce some aspect of
their lives among them emerson and
nietzsche but many others spanning the
visual arts and music and philosophy and
prose uh the talk he will give tonight
which i'm going to assume is up to some
extent stemming from the recent work on
renunciation
certainly starts okay uh is called on
the pleasures of
self-misunderstanding how one becomes
what one is in isha and emerson
please join me in welcoming ross posner
thanks very much professor grimstad and
for the invitation
i want to start with two interlocking
facts about emerson and his avid admirer
nietzsche the first is the biographical
fact of renunciation
they both quit soul-killing institutions
citadels of conformity and formalism
and the second fact is a shared
commitment to enlarging philosophy
beyond simply the intellectual labor
that produces sermons and articles and
books
renunciation is the pivot by which each
man brings life and work together in a
dynamic unity such continuity makes them
akin to the ancients for whom philosophy
was a way of life rather than a
compartmentalized subject matter this is
the
the consuming interest of pierre ado the
great french
historian
in my paper's second part i'll heed the
imperative to bring life and work
together and give an account
of uh that unity from my own experience
to maximize the urgency of abandoning
one's sterile profession emerson and
nietzsche
construct a sturdy dichotomy of life
versus books that is as simplistic and
contradictory as it is inspiring
they in effect sacrifice intellectual
subtlety on the altar of life's
exigencies in short the dichotomy is
catalytic it functions above all as a
way to produce the emotional momentum
needed to renounce
or to use an emersonian word to make a
transition from from institutional
affiliation for emerson the unitarian
ministry for nietzsche a university
department of classical languages
the move to a less disciplinary place
where a genius whom nietzsche defines as
he who wants to augment nature with new
living nature might thrive
end quote the very last place that
thriving would occur is in an academic
chair where as nietzsche says
one is obligated to think in public
about predetermined subjects at
predetermined hours
he says this makes philosophical thought
quote emasculated from the first
so he wasn't long for the academy
his strategy is a counter strategy to
quote educate ourselves against our age
he seeks liberating philosophical
exemplars men of genius those of quote
unconstrained and unhampered natural
being
whose books are less intellectual than
quote physiological experiences that
produce quote the magical outpouring of
the inner strength of one natural
creature onto another
reading schopenhauer produced this
rapturous exchange yet it's very medium
robbed it of full power
nietzsche informs us but i had
discovered him only in the forum of a
book and that was a great deficiency so
i strove all the harder to see through
the book and to imagine the living man
just as william james upon whom whose
infant form emerson bestowed a blessing
according to james family lore
just as william james in 1907 will urge
his auditors to quote return to life and
not let his lecture quote teach the
lesson he urges us to be deafened to
talk he says
james
nietzsche esteems what the book cannot
encompass the outward life in its
corporeal presence what he calls the
quote courageous visibility of the
philosophical life
this is egregiously absent in germany
where kant this is nietzsche's favorite
example clung to his university
submitted himself to its regulations and
his example produced only quote
professorial philosophy
and professor and professors quote kant
has had a living and life transforming
influence on only a very few men
end quote what counts for nietzsche is
to abandon that half-life in the academy
and achieve courageous visibility
equality inherited from the ancient
greeks who taught according to nietzsche
through their very bearing
through what they wore and what they ate
and their morals rather than what rather
than by what they said let alone by what
they wrote
so diogenes the cynic for instance is a
great favorite example for for nietzsche
a disturbing thinker who he actually
links to emerson
the thinker's physical bearing embodied
in quote every glance in every gesture
expresses the fused unity of body and
spirit and this insistence on life as a
whole undergirds their commitment to
visibility and counts as their most
valuable teaching
although nietzsche had taught for a
decade in the compar
comparatively free thinking environment
of basel switzerland
nietzsche in 1879 left the university
and left the invisibility of his
professorship in greek language and
literature with its heavy teaching load
and that was burdening as always
precarious health
thanks in part to a generous yearly
pension from the university he never
needed another job thus fulfilling what
he called his public promise made five
years earlier in schopenhauer as
educator from which the above quotations
derive
in this essay
nietzsche twice quotes from emerson
circles to inspire his own effort of
emancipation from the shackles of
professional philosophy
and he anticipates the opening of
william james's pragmatism which mocks
quote the refinement and rationalism
that insulate sterilizes classroom
philosophy they're all very much of a
piece william james
nietzsche and emerson about this
nietzsche declares quote and this again
is very jamesy and the only critique of
a philosophy that is possible and that
proves something in the academy is
namely trying to see whether one can
live in accordance with it
that's never been taught
all that's ever been taught is a
critique of words by means of other
words
end quote to escape the closed circuit
of language nietzsche embraces the what
embraces life and will consign books for
the scholars idle times to borrow
emerson's famously perverse phrase in
the american scholar
but the animus against the bookish grows
deeper as nietzsche makes clear a
philosopher he says is not merely a
great thinker
but also a real human being
and when did a scholar ever become a
real human being so this is the the
severity of nietzsche's animus again
it's
somewhat theatrical i think
emerson posed the same question about
preachers
who can forget his portrait and divinity
school address of the preacher who
sorely tempted emerson says to say i
would go to church no more
this is a
famous passage you might know
a snowstorm was falling around us the
snowstorm was real the preacher merely
spectral
and the eye left
and the eye felt the sad contrast and
looking at him and then out of the
window behind him into the beautiful
meteor of the snow the preacher had
lived in vain he had not one word
intimating that he had laughed or wept
was married or in love if he'd ever
lived and acted we were none the wiser
for it
end quote
1838 the same year as this address to
the harvard divinity students is when
emerson fills his notebooks with
discontent about being a preacher
just uh for the record in 1832 he had
resigned the ministry of boston's second
church but lately it agreed to preach
each sunday at the east lexington church
so he was still in touch with that
apparent from the notebooks is that
emerson's second resignation from the
unitarian church is above all a dispute
over language
he's frustrated at the strictures the
ministry places on the way language is
to be used in the pulpit
to renounce the church is to renounce
its approved mode of preaching
language in the service of the formulaic
that is language wholly indifferent to
the task emerson comes to see as crucial
finding ways to write and speak
sentences that approximate the
volatility that courses through nature
and human being
his journal entries from near the near
this time
of about uh 1838 quitting is
there they're at once blunt and
intricate
quote i hate goodies i hate goodness
that preaches
goodness that preaches undoes itself a
little
a little electricity of virtue lurks
here and there in kitchens and among the
obscure chiefly women
and it flashes out occasional light and
makes the existence of the things still
credible
goodies make us very bad we will almost
sin to spite them
true to the perverse pulse of life
paraded goodness sparks and spectators
its opposite desire to sin
that's basically emerson's logic here
emerson reprises his contempt for what
he earlier derided as quote official
goodness preordained self-advertised
virtue that distracts us from noting
unscripted outcroppings of actual virtue
in class and gender precincts out of
bourgeois bounds
quote goodness that preaches undoes
itself
meaning it logically negates itself but
emerson's imagery of an electric charge
inherent in are part of something that
flashes out with light in a sort of
involuntary natural process
helps solve the logical problem he set
up for himself in defining goodness as
self-contained
if goodness or virtue exists in itself
and silently
how could you ever know it's there
virtue or goodness if it's to be
communicated has to be done so
involuntarily as a natural force like
electricity it does it does exist
without being known and that's proved by
the incalculable way in which it comes
to be present
he states quote i find in me no
enthusiasm no resources for the
instruction and guidance of the people
when they shall discover that their
present guides are blind this is a
notebook remark
he continues this this convention of
education is cold i hate preaching
whether in pupil whether
in pulpits or teachers meetings
preaching is a pledge and i wish to say
what i think and feel today with the
proviso that tomorrow perhaps i shall
contradict it all
preaching is lifeless because it stymies
the very rhythm of life to be sliding in
his word not fixed teeming with excess
and opposites dualities and
contradiction
depending on fixity and coherence
instruction guide us repress and
simplify
thereby seducing congregants into
obedience sapping their capacity to
think for themselves
and the same penalty afflicts he who
dispenses guidance it is a pledge whose
cost is too high diminished
responsibility and responsiveness in the
present
he notes i always find that my views
chill or shock people
and uh
no wonder for for in setting words in
motion they as if generate the electric
charge is talking about quote the shock
whereas
in contrast a minister he says nowadays
is plain as pros the pros of prose
so the moralizing drone of quote odious
religion extols a vacuous goodness
for emerson again this is all carefully
set up for his departure
the severance from received ideas that
emerson and nietzsche offer is an ordeal
by fire
each author writes texts that undermine
their own authority and the reader's
reliance on that authority let me or let
me put it this way they seek to induce a
renunciation in the reader that mimes
the renunciation that first brings the
text into being
when he says for instance i unsettle all
things emerson can be understood as
speaking of a will to severance that
spreads from the church ministry to the
reader's dependency on him
nietzsche too values what unsettles for
him
the capacity of what he calls being
perplexed and this is a he says is the
origin of philosophy uh not simply
wonder the ancient basis of philosophy
but being perplexed is essential for
encouraging critical thought
the commitment to unsettlement losing
one's bearings is therapeutic a means of
inducing change a return to life a
william james phrase rather than an
abiding with books but the return is to
a life stripped of a governing hierarchy
mind no longer proceeds and defines
experience but instead grasps what
heidegger calls the quote unthought
background of thought
the non-conceptual receptivity and
feeling that's under the radar of
cognition blind intuitive tacit as one
quote we do something without knowing
how or why
the famous phrase to describe emerson's
notion of abandonment or transition
which
is analogous to what nietzsche calls the
innocence of becoming
these are zones of the inarticulable
where doing without knowing prevails and
we must trust our own feelings left on
their own by disorienting renunciating
texts
untethered readers face an uneasy
emancipation
at this point i want to take seriously
their injunctions to renounce the book
and return to life to be left on my own
to exhibit if not exactly a courageous
visibility than at least to turn mildly
autobiographical i want to show how both
writers in their shared devotion to
exposing the limits of rational
deliberation help illuminate helped
illuminate a perplexity or opacity in my
own life and in so doing they sharpen my
frustration with the pervasive
rationalism of our most prestigious
intellectual paradigm post-modernism
and some here is my testimony to the
quote living and life-transforming
influence that emerson and nietzsche
both seek
perhaps like me you have a propensity to
collect books without quite knowing why
over the years i've piled up volumes by
by and about say wittgenstein hannah
arendt george santiano phillip roth ad
reinhardt philip gustin
franz rosenzweig penelope fitzgerald
philip reef
a motley crew
and not only not read them but not had
any not but did not have any desire to
read them i i was busy working on other
things and for a decade or two they
simply gathered dust on my shelves
but then inevitably i will i would be
drawn to these nearly forgotten volumes
and strangely they would prove pivotal
to a new project
i recall for instance that santiana
ascended literally from the obscurity of
a low shelf to earn a chapter in my book
on william and henry james wittgenstein
made an analogous of more circuitous
journey from the shadows waiting
untouched until five years ago when i
kept a long-held inner vow to read
another languishing tome one that had
stared me down so often it had acquired
an aura of intimidation stanley cabell's
the claim of reason
that can shine skepticism morality and
tragedy
it was indeed intimidating but also
inspiring that experience opened the
door to more cavall and to deeper
engagements with emerson and to
wittgenstein who was who joined the sage
of concord and nietzsche as a figure in
a current project mentioned in the
introduction on artists and philosophers
and writers who renounce their careers
the peculiarities of my manner of book
buying the absence of full consciousness
and the long gap between acquisition and
reading puts me in mind of walter
benjamin's famous essay unpacking my
library it starts with the premise that
quote every passion borders on the
chaotic and finds that the passion of
the book collector unleashes a chaos of
memories where in each purchase says
benjamin chance and fate
and quote seem to jostle against one
another
benjamin speaks his library as the quote
a custom confusion of these books for
what else is this collection but a
disorder to which habit has accommodated
itself to such an extent that it can
appear as order
for decades the chaos of my own book
collecting was a form of disorder that
blurred agency and intuition
chance and fate
and though this this disorder helped
shape my intellectual life it had been
masked by habit and so escaped my
reflective notice that is until a recent
encounter with a passage from nietzsche
helped shed light but before that
something else intervened to do to nudge
me to interrogate my habit
around uh 2002 when i decided to write a
book on philip roth i had it hand most
of his novels having dutifully acquired
them over the years and true to form
remaining largely indifferent to reading
them
so they were just sitting there
but as i borrowed into roth's work
however i grew aware of his close
friendship with the painter philip
gustin a relationship that had become
basic to my understanding of what i was
then calling roth's aesthetics of
immaturity that understanding was built
on what was also somehow at hand a pile
of monographs and articles on the
painter philip gustin that that i had
carefully if inexplicably been gathering
over years
now they were no longer inert objects
but palpable presences both uh this
patient's stack of roth and dustin
material had undergone a transformation
that now struck me as more than a
serendipitous accident
for the first time i wondered what was
going on how did i explain my
my thoughtless buying and deferred
reading what game was my unconscious
playing
it seemed to be busy busily working
subliminally as if behind my mind's back
replacing deliberate effort with
intuition or instinct in order to
quicken receptivity keeping me in a
period of prolonged incubation as i
filled my shells in advance of my
conscious turn to works that would prove
crucial
was it a professorial enactment of what
emerson called abandonment abandonment
the one thing which we seek with
insatiable desire as he said to forget
ourselves to do something without
knowing how or why in short to draw a
new circle
this famous passage which uh is the
final paragraph of his exhilarating
essay circles it had always been a
personal favorite of mine and a
pedagogical uh touchstone in my lectures
but who knew i was living it
the possibility that i was indeed living
my own bookish version of abandonment
that i had unwittingly hence
appropriately been drawing emersonian
circles apparently for decades this
sense this possibility received sharp
confirmation last year
teaching a seminar on emerson and
nietzsche i encountered a passage from
the latter's autobiography ekehomo how
one becomes what one is section nine of
why i am so clever
this at last crystallized matters
with brazen perversity nietzsche
replaces the venerable venerable nada
motto know thyself he calls us now a
recipe for ruin
with quote self-misunderstanding
and describes his own self becoming as a
miracle of self-forgetting
he begins by declaring quote at this
point the real answer to the question
how one becomes what one is can no
longer be avoided the question
presupposes that what this is nietzsche
that one must not have the faintest
notion what one is
from this perspective again quoting even
the blunders of life the side paths and
wrong turnings have their own meaning
and value end quote as if nietzsche
acknowledges that one's
self-estrangements awaken one
from the tunnel vision that plagues that
certain knower
what nietzsche portrays
homo is the coming to being of the most
innocent of selves innocent is his word
that is one free from resontima and full
of irresponsibility his word a lightness
gained from relinquishing the guilt
instilled by religion and other
institutions of control
knowledge is warded off permitting the
quote surface of consciousness to be
kept clear of any of what nietzsche
calls the great imperatives
desires words attitudes
all of this is kept clear because they
would burden one with responsibility and
goals and make one a man of knowledge
the grand words represent he says so
many dangers that the instinct comes too
soon to understand itself and it will be
clogged with meaning
keeping therefore an end quote keeping
consciousness clear thus allows the
eventual organizing powers to grow in
the dark as it were quote deep down in
the depths
itself with the capacity to evaluate
values requires an especially intricate
psychic development
contrary capacities and quote must be
cultivated and must be carefully
protected from awareness of the quote
secret labor of the instincts
nietzsche tells us how he thrived as a
stranger to himself
this is all nietzsche considered in this
way my life is simply wonderful
i've never even suspected what was
growing within me and one day all my
capacities suddenly right leap forth in
their ultimate perfection i cannot
remember having taken any trouble no
trace of struggle can be demonstrated in
my life i am the opposite of a heroic
nature
willing something striving for something
envisioning envisaging a purpose a wish
i know none of this
from my experience
at this moment i will look upon my
future as upon a calm sea there is no
ripple of desire i do not want in the
least that anything should become
different than it is i myself do not
want to become different but that's how
i've always lived i had no wishes a man
over 44 who can say he never strove for
honors or for women or for money but it
happened for example one day i was a
university professor no such idea had
ever entered my head for i was barely 24
years old
end quote
and why i am so clever nietzsche depicts
himself here as a veteran
excuse me as a virgin of his character
zarathustra that human being redeemed
from the spirit of revenge and a herald
of the ubermensch
of course on one level this
self-portrait projects a grandiose
aristocratic fantasy of immaculate
effortlessness
this is the nietzsche who was always for
generations intoxicated undergraduate
esthetes
even inspiring the famous
lethal pair leopold and loeb in chicago
in the 1920s
rich boys who were
drunk on nietzsche and murdered a
neighbor
a young child
yet the self-portrait
on one level grandiose also deflates
grandiosity by making manifest the
self-overcoming that nietzsche prizes
when we experience the impersonality of
ourselves rather than affirming our
familiar sense of identity
this impersonality we are meaning we are
straight strangers to ourselves we do
not comprehend ourselves to recall his
words um from the start of the preface
to the genealogy of morals strangers to
ourselves
is a salutary rebuke to the fantasy dear
to the western male psyche
of the sovereign individual as
self-knowing master of experience
willing something striving for something
envisaging a purpose a wish i know none
of this from experience
so nietzsche is renouncing the
deliberative self who formulates a plan
of life as uh j.s miller would have it a
plan of life and renouncing know thyself
and it's correlative to thine own self
be true as foolish polonius put it
nietzsche challenges us to bear not
knowing to live without why in other
words to let instinct speak
to us openly
and it's it also means to open new and
hidden energies in the self beyond the
reach of rational cognition that are
normally blocked in the act of
self-reflection
nietzsche in some loosens the hold of
the cartesian cogito which makes knowing
subjects foundational
he shares this philosophic
anti-intellectualism the proposition
that all experiences a mode of knowing
with among others is beloved emerson and
his contemporary william james for
instance william james's theory of
emotion insists on the primacy of the
body we're afraid because we tremble
rather than the common sense opposite
it also includes uh as fellow
anti-intellectualist
wittgenstein who says that one when one
acts with comfortable certainty one is
to be regarded as quote a creature in a
primitive state
and when one follows rules one does so
blindly
for these figures as for john dewey mind
is embodied and experience is not a
knowledge affair but rather is where
things are suffered and endured
or had before cognized that's dewey's
point they're had before cognized
the passage from why i'm so clever hit
home for it made sense of my own self
opacity the passage also made me feel
rather heady as if i was now licensed to
consecrate my blind book buying on the
altar of the nietzschean ubermensch
amazon unbound
my temptation to self-transport seemed
not wholly inappropriate when i
reflected that as the emerson nietzsche
seminar revealed on more than one
occasion emerson's praise of whim
intuition and institutions seems at
times to intoxicate nietzsche and
inspire him to new heights of rhetorical
audacity
after the revelation afforded by eke
homo i revisited emerson's essay
intellect
to see if it it if it too it stole the
virtues of self-forgetting
not only did the essay offer more shocks
of recognition but its discomforting
thesis that quote we have little control
over our thoughts
thanks to the superiority of the
spontaneous or intuitive principle over
the arithmetical or logical end quote
contains seeds that flower in eke homo's
portrayal of how nietzsche became what
he is
intellect emerson's essay
also made explicit what i had
unwittingly lived that intuition
according to emerson is a quote taking
in stride that has a complex temporality
since in emerson's version of intuition
quote the mind does not immediately
intuit what it has taken in stride
his idea of intuition and hence its
strangeness is counter-intuitive as
branca arsich has shown in her subtle
reading of this essay
long prior says emerson long prior to
the age of reflection is the thinking of
the mind out of darkness it came
insensibly into the marvelous light of
today
this lag between thinking and reflection
occurs says arsich because quote
perceptions affect one another in the
intellect without the mind knowing
anything about it
this explains why emerson responding to
his rhetorical question quote what is
the hardest task in the world answers to
think
this dramatically reverses the cartesian
cogito remarks arshig arsic here i is
what cannot think what is not entrusted
with the power to think she says
emerson notes that logic is not absent
in us but is quote virtual and latent
within the within the intuitive
principle logic he says is the
procession or proportionate unfolding of
the intuition but its virtue is as
silent method the moment it would appear
as propositions and have a separate
value it is worthless
what makes thinking so hard and why
deferral is as if built into it is the
incorrigibility of our will it doesn't
control our power of thought what am i
emerson asks
what has my will done to make me that i
am
nothing i have been floated into this
thought this hour this connection of
events by secret currents of might and
mind and my ingenuity and willfulness
have not thwarted have not aided me to
any appreciable degree
our truth of thought is therefore
vitiated this is all emerson our truth
of thought is therefore vitiated as much
by too violent direction given by our
will as by two great negligence we do
not determine what we will think we only
open our senses clear away as we can all
obstruction from the fact and suffer the
intellect to see we have little control
of our thoughts
end quote in other words intellect grows
spontaneously without effort
some image word or fact will imprint
itself on our mind and that adherence to
gradually germinates unfolding he says
like a vegetable bud
he says your first an instinct then an
opinion then a knowledge as the plant
has root bud and fruit
trust the instinct to the end though you
can render no reason it's vain to hurry
it by trusting it to the end it shall
ripen into truth and you shall know why
you believe
nietzsche and emerson shared suspicion
of the will to self-knowledge and their
trust and instinct
also precipitated my turn to another
volume that had spent decades untended
on my shelf
michael palani's personal knowledge
when earlier i described my pre
pre-reflective literary habits as
amounting to a prolonged period of
incubation
i borrowed this word from polany his
book never read long owned and surviving
multiple moves its cram poorly printed
pages now made all the more uninviting
by thin yellowing paper and a and a
cracking paperback spine
just uh
i was oblivious to it over the years
though lured by its title and some of
its headings
the art of knowing intellectual passions
the tacit component i would periodically
rescue the book from my chronic
negligence taking it up in a burst of
enthusiasm only to set it aside my
impulse rebuked still too much science i
rationalized and besides the print was a
trial and the page is loose
but in the wake of my nietzschean and
emersonian-induced epiphanies the moment
of personal knowledge had arrived i was
ready at last for its central point
which is quote we feel our way to
success without without specifiably
knowing how we do it this tacit
dimension this is that's the title of a
better known polany volume is a quote
immense mental domain acquired he says
by effort which went beyond the hitherto
assured capacity of some person making
it it relied on an act of groping which
originally passed the understanding of
its agent and of which he has ever since
remained only subsidiarily aware as part
of a complex achievement
this was a meta moment surprised by
english professors a work that
celebrated groping knowledge
unspecifiable ineffable unempirical
mirrored the very groping i had long
been tacitly practicing
most recently when i plucked personal
knowledge from my seeming oblivion at a
propitious moment
trust the instinct to the end emerson
said though you can render no reason
it's vain to hurry it um i seem to be
confirming that
trust in feeling one's way informally in
the absence of conscious action typifies
what poiani calls the incubation period
of discovery
during incubation nothing happens on the
level of consciousness or behavior even
as we're preoccupied unconsciously he
says the fact that our intellectual
strivings make effective progress during
a period of incubation without any
effort on our part is in line with the
latent character of all knowledge
uh personal knowledge is an is the
magnum opus of uh a distinguished
hungarian chemist who abandoned science
for philosophy politics and economics
uh personal knowledge from 1958 has
always been in the shadows of a more
famous work that it anticipates thomas
kuhn's the structure of scientific
revolutions
from uh 62.
as polyani's most recent biographer
remarks most people first know of him
from kum's remark and structure
commending his notion of tacit knowledge
palani's work which joined cunes as
foundational for the new field the
social construction of science argued
for an alternative to the positivist
model of scientific inquiry as unalloyed
objectivity and rational deliberation
for polioni true discovery is not a
strictly logical performance but
requires plunges and leaps across
logical gaps
he says in a passage that grows
increasingly lyrical especially when we
consider his scientific background
neither subjective nor objective but
transcending their opposition personal
knowledge is science
excuse me personal knowledge in science
is not made but discovered and as such
it claims to establish contact with
reality beyond the clues on which it
relies
it commits us passionately and far
beyond our comprehension to a vision of
reality of this responsibility we cannot
divest ourselves by setting up objective
criteria of verifiability for we live in
it as the garment of our skin like love
to which it is akin this comment
commitment is to a shirt of flame
phrase of t.s eliot
assured a flame blazing with passion and
also like love consumed by devotion to a
universal demand such as the true sense
of objectivity in science says pliani
so he joined science to art and
mysticism and breaking through the
screen of objectivity drawing he says
are preconceptual capacities of
contemplative vision capacity shared he
repeatedly shows by infants and
chimpanzees like james and dewey paulani
wants to rescue experience from those
observers and instrumentalists who quote
guided by experience pass through
experience without experiencing it
experiencing it in itself they want to
go through experience without
experiencing it what happens what keeps
us aloof from things their sound sights
smell and touch is the very conceptual
framework by which we observe and
manipulate things
scientific discovery demolishes one
accepted framework
uh after another more
to construct another more rigorous one
but that act of revision and discovery
quote burst the bounds of discipline
thought in an intensive transient moment
of heuristic vision overwhelmed by its
own passionate activity says playani
this turbulence of creative freedom that
defies if for a moment the bounds of
disciplined thought recalls kant's
conception of genius as a force of
originality indifferent to rules
hence the genius says khan this is in
the third critique does not himself know
how the ideas for it have entered into
his head nor has he in it in his power
to invent the like at pleasure or
methodically and to communicate the same
to others in such precepts as would
enable them to produce similar products
genius in other words dwells in the
tacit dimension
it's well known that post-modernism has
no patience for genius not least because
it smacks
too much of allegiance to liberal
humanism's fondness for sovereign
subjectivity and even some great man
theory of history
but let's note it is that post-modern
theory tends to have a consistent blind
spot regarding the tacit dimension and
the precognitive in general symptoms of
their more pervasive suspicion of the
unmediated be it instinct sensation the
unconscious intuition the flashes of
responsiveness and receptivity generated
by the body
as nietzsche says in eke homo my genius
is in my nostrils
and in the twilight of idols he mocks
the philosopher's idolatry of reason
reason is what causes us to falsify the
testimony of the senses
whereas nietzsche's naturalism provides
an actual history of moral norms which
is what he means by the notion of
genealogy
postmodernism makes unrelenting war on
the natural this is sort of
in the 80s 70s and 80s nietzsche was a
hero of post-modernism here i'm trying
to suggest
they're oppositional
postmodernism makes unrelenting war on
the natural reducing the self to an
ideologically constructed identity forms
of intellectualism pervade postmodern
theory for instance belief in the
ubiquity of textualism certainly the
early derida
rhetoric and figurality uh demand uh
interpretations of the ubiquity of all
these things interpretation stanley fish
and intention at walter ben michaels one
result is that they at postmodern
theorists inadvertently reinstate the
gap between nature and culture body and
mind emotion and reason and leave
feeling or any immediate experience or
sensation under suspicion as hopelessly
naive
interestingly it's visual artists and
writers about art who've been very
receptive to this uh limit in
post-modernism because visual artists
often seem to embody or perform this
naivete immersed in the hands-on
interplay with paint and canvas
they're therefore and relatedly often
evasive or reticent regarding requests
to stand back and explain the meaning of
their art
they sort of renounce that
responsibility
but they're rich in tacit knowing and
intuition and this makes them willing to
follow what the materials in hand seem
to want to do
whereas literature as damon famously
wrote is quote the only form of language
free from the fallacy of unmediated
expression
end quote the practitioners of visual
art tend to tended to embrace the
fallacy of the unmediated in their
relish of the violence of sensation
for instance in his famous interviews
with david sylvester the painter francis
bacon speaks repeatedly of painting as
an effort to record quote one's own
one's own feelings as closely to one's
own nervous system as one possibly can
end quote in effect it was the job of
post-modern art theorists to tidy up the
artist's naive belief in the power of
the visceral which was grounded in
engagement with obdurately palpable
materials
but postmodern's programmatic suspicion
over claims of naivete has produced a
counter response predictably
one that art historians
have started to articulate uh one
richard schiff
in his book doubt
2008 says
claims for the ubiquitous efficacy of
cultural forces may be creating a more
pernicious mythology than belief in
aesthetic immediacy and naturalness
end quote
schiff's doubts about postmodern
orthodoxy leave him as he says hanging
his phrase he says it does not entail
being convinced of the real existence of
the natural self that certain artists
may be continuing to seek as a
liberating alternative to culture
it does not entail this rather our doubt
merely indicates how deeply
dissatisfying it is to believe that
there can be no natural self and no
physical existence at all no source of
sensation that might escape the
generalizing sameness of our various
cultural identities
schiff in short is tired he says of
being pressured by the critical
indoctrination which trains uh trains us
he says all too readily to expose the
superficiality the constructed spectacle
the mirage of sensation to distrust our
feelings more than to trust them
schiff asks quote to what degree are we
willing to trust and act on feeling
especially when no theory supports it
he urges us to quote stop conflating the
history of the criticism and theory of
art with the history of making art
the former depends on what he says is a
fantasy world of the general and
conceptual that can only lead away from
the sensory world of the specific and
the real
though theory encouraged him to be quote
extraordinarily wary of many of the
claims of modern artists
schiff now tries to resist his own
distrust in his effort to keep faith in
feeling he enlists polioni's personal
knowledge when asked in an interview
what's worth caring about schiff says
that we need to understand our quote
cultural hunger to experience what
escapes conceptualization
this hungers deep in the american grain
emerson called the hunger abandonment
and his greatest reader nietzsche
alerted me last year that i too had this
hunger for decades i've been feeding it
in my own acts of biblio abandonment my
intuitive book buying the urge to quote
do something without knowing how or why
in short to draw a new circle thanks
you have time for questions of uh ross
you're willing to sure sure i would
especially encourage
uh students who are taking the course
please feel free to speak up and ask
questions it's a very rich
bracing talk and i'm sure there's lots
of things to discuss the floor is open
you're welcome
yeah go ahead
oh
um
is that has formal characteristics it's
not this kind of undifferentiated
non-institutionalized thing you need to
have the school you need to have the
spiritual discipline you get a school
to have a really practical philosophy
so uh and that that just raises two
things i guess for you one one is that
uh
it seems to me that the opposition
between
institutional
forms of knowing
um and the kind of feeling of being free
and alive when you know something that
is historically
uh inflected um
i think the late 19th century is a
crucial moment in which it some seems to
become possible for scholars to believe
that
by being a scholar by being a
professional scholar you can also
practice
uh pre-noted knowledge um i think this
has a larger to do with the
adoption of these kind of german
protocols
from the university
but so i guess did you have people in
mind who were happy professors
yeah um i work
oh in anthropology that young okay
differentiates itself and becomes a
plausible enterprise as opposed to this
kind of classical rogue philology that
someone like emerson study when it
becomes possible to imagine that by
studying modern texts you are kind of
participating as in the first personal
way in this reproduction of a cultural
tradition
and that it's not divorced or not
opposed to life
is quite compatible with the hot dog
perspective on being in school
well you mean spiritual exercises that's
i think ado says yeah yes absolutely
right
but in that respect you then have to ask
well how different is that from what
someone like
about
the way that knowledge is a form of
practical
uh a form of practice that is uh
in us
well i think that's part of foucault's
dislike of what he called the general
intellectual that would not be an
emersonian
the the non-affiliated the specific
intellectual is inside right right
for most of us
i i i kind of agree right you guys how
far i want to go i don't want to go too
far i i tried to cue
my quotations by saying that they were
theatricalizing um but
i would i
i don't know if i disagree but i i think
that
the william james william james starts
pragmatism by mocking classroom
philosophy
um it's a city on a hill and he says it
breathes refinement and he's
contemptuous of the harvard his harvard
colleagues in the department and he's
he's also using the word refinement to
extend to
uh social gentility
and
their indifference to
social suffering poverty and he talks
about he he has newspaper clips that an
anarchist had given him about a
cleveland working man who killed himself
and his family from poverty and he says
this this is the multitudinous street
that the world the world of uh that's
beyond the university's grasp this is
what pragmatism's going to dwell in
and that commit that james in commitment
is enormously influential for people
like randolph-born and the 20s
intellectuals like mumford and and van
wyk brooks they're all on edmond wilson
they're all unaffiliated they're they're
firmly
uh
susan sontag kenneth kenneth burke
is a teacher susan sontags at university
of chicago kenneth burke is a later
generation mid-century version of the
unaffiliated he teaches occasionally but
he helps inculcate and son tag
a adamant
almost instinctive contempt for
institutions
i mean if you read her journal she's
saying that something like when she's 18
years old i know i'm never going to
teach in other words
i i hear exactly what you're saying but
there is a broad emersonian jamesian
current of anti-institutionalism
uh
that puts me in
a question that i want to ask which is
you know obviously these unaffiliated
have followers and students
in the sense
your talk is a good example of not an
institutionalization but of
turning these ideas into a practice
you did it you discovered it it's
repeatable
i wanted to ask you if you thought this
takes me to a conceptual question do you
think that there's a difference between
renunciation
and abandonment
oh
do you want to say you want me to say
the difference or imagine the difference
or do you want to tell me and i'll react
to it
well i i should say that i i don't
fetishize the word running renunciation
in my own work
abandonment is more visceral for emerson
it's more visceral more immediate i
think
um the way of life is wonderful it's by
abandonment to do something without
knowing how or why renunciation could be
much more intellectual formal
but what's your your i wonder if you
could renounce something without also
having in mind something to take
oh i see
i think that the ren
either one is is uh
never
forsaken
they're not blotted out they i'm most
interested in acts of renunciation that
then become a compositional resource in
the work of the renunciator
like like emerson for instance
or nietzsche
where the act of renunciation is
propelling their work
it's it's figured in their work
but you wanted to say something earlier
yeah um
like different capacities within
ourselves
and i'm wondering if it might be
possible or whether paradoxical talk
about self-cultivation
i think you're advocating for
yeah that's interesting you mean if not
knowledge at least a receptivity
perhaps like
if maybe to put it in colloquial terms
um
we need to be more in touch with
ourselves
can we consciously work on doing that
i mean it seems paradoxical from the
start
you mean to like to be spontaneous you
know to be
yeah it's very tricky um
but it may be that nietzsche and emerson
are trying to do just that
or with the notion that that was
discussed in class today about
impressionability
um
for emerson you can't help but be
constantly um
bombarded by
things in the atmosphere he says and so
you're always already
intuiting way beyond your
uh rational capacities
um
so in class today
we discussed
sort of the
aspect of circles that are limiting and
so you get pooped in
how do you think in terms of your
discussion of amendment and
pronunciation
limiting
property of circles sort of fits into
that
the limiting property of it
how does how do limitations fit into
renunciation
that circumscribe circumstances
conditions
i guess renunciators are acutely
uh
aware of limits or they insist on limits
i mean
renunciation could be
an act of willful
drawing of limits precisely to feel
frustrated
i mean i i think the important thing
in their theatrical is that what i'm
calling their theatricalization of their
uh animus about institutions is
is the need to gain momentum to leave so
feeling confined
is important for them you know in a way
to cultivate the way that people say
james joyce cultivated his
ambivalences toward ireland he needed to
feel in flight from it
he was nursing it
you feel um by and i was really
interested by the way you were talking
about post-modernism
intellectualism and i was wondering if
you found it if you would find it to be
a helpful parallel to look at emerson's
um the way he tries to escape faith and
apply that or think about the way we
could possibly get out of this conundrum
of postmodern
that's fascinating
um
is there a lesson in the essay fate for
um
i'm not sure um
i certainly nothing leaps to mine um
were you did you have something in mind
unless
we would insist with emerson that
everything has its opposite and that to
embrace fate is to embrace freedom at
the same time and so we could say
post-modernism is failing to
heed emerson's insistence on
opposites that things are and are not at
the same time
you know that
as he says a nominalist and realist
every every sentence is true and untrue
every sentence holds a lie
so
the flight from feeling in this in this
strain of postmodernism may be a kind of
impoverishment from not being in touch
with that vision of opposites
perhaps
uh i have a question permit me to
indulge in a bit of intellectualism
a question about about uh the passive
and implicit and assumed uh uh
uh divergence or polarity between the
conceptual and the affective in your
talk there seems to be a really accepted
distinction between here's a here are
immediate sensual sensory affects and
they can be undergone and felt and
here's this other realm which is the
abstracting universalizing the
conceptual the linguistic casting
everything into words somehow
sterilizing the sensual and the affect
by casting it into words but we're
getting this so first of all there's a
lot of philosophy of the 20th century
most of it that follows from the
tradition of pragmatism that really
offers a somewhat more uh a more uh
complex account the relation between
affect and concepts begins with sellers
on the myth of the given rorty obviously
who i assume you include as part of this
uh uh
landscape of post-modernism and
textualism and and verbalism yeah rorty
would be probably the most blatant
offender right he really is a textualist
through and through but he's getting
that through a certain pragmatist
intellectual history that begins with
the problem of the means of the giving
surely emerson and nietzsche are great
artists and pros surely they're great uh
uh masters of concepts of arranging
words their only access to their work is
through
the conceptual we we're getting
everything verbalized and verbalized in
a really kind of striking and memorable
way that's why we continue to read them
so what happens to your distinction
between the affective and the conceptual
uh when you consider that that
relationship
and undergone a lot of changes in the
pragmatist tradition in the 20th century
the second part of the question is that
what you're calling post-modernist
textualism
in fact the latest sort of developments
and mutations in let's say
post-structuralist thought after say the
influence of duluth has been absolute
insistence on the immediate and the
affective and the sense i would say to
lose people like toulouse or leotard or
important counterpoint but surely that's
part of the broad cultural and
intellectual topography that you're
mapping out and saying this is all
enthralled to a kind of
okay so you're saying a certain kind of
i said a certain strain that's
influential had been influential there's
certainly important counter strains
probably i don't mean to describe the
situation right now i would say with the
advent of deliz and other developments
affect theory of course
um
in a way the problem's been solved but
isn't that prone to all the lapses into
immediacy in the myth of the given that
so much one philosophy of language has
been laboring yeah i i take your point
and you're absolutely right in terms of
the history of
philosophy
but uh
literary
figures don't seem to worry too much
about these nuances
but
again back to william james william
james
makes very romantic
unnuanced rejections of concepts and his
late work that
but he does say i'm not saying um
get rid of concepts he's talking about
not being enslaved to them not taking
them as definitive
um
yeah but it's an it's a problem of of
degree of course we have we were wedded
to concepts um
but he then
his passion is to
critique what he calls the conceptual
decomposition of life
um getting back to rorty for a minute
rorty is uh a completely perverse figure
because he
purports to be the
the heir to dewey
and he has absolutely no patience with
the pre-linguistic at all and uh
so he
knows why that happened
because he comes from an analytic
background and he didn't want to be
embarrassed by the flagrant romanticism
of of james so he speaks of
uh
try to shut your ears or your eyes to
james when he's as he says
diving into the bergsonian flux you know
it's just an embarrassment to rorty
but
i don't think that's a
very rich response to
the fact that james is interested in
diving into the flux
yeah i wonder what
you could say a kind of criticism of
emerson and i guess nature from another
angle which i guess
marks
thinking about
the bodies in another way which is the
way that you know this immediately
i mean
would you
share the sense that or when you look at
these thinkers
um
are they
missing something important that i think
you know melville
in emerson
and i guess sort of the marxist
tradition which is running concurrent
and not quite
making a meeting until
the 20th century
um
when you
leave this they want to leave the
discipline they want to announce
justice behind also
that's a very important question
we saw today in a
emerson's essay fate
it's
an essay in which slavery figures very
uh
quietly unmistakably but not forcefully
and centrally
emerson did
rise to the occasion
when
the abolitionist asked him to
join their cause in the early 1850s
and
he he insisted on
anti-slavery as a position but he he had
a deeper point uh we talked about it
today earlier that um
he had his own he said in the journal
entry that he had his own slaves to free
meaning readers
you know man is timid and apologetic a
dwarf
self-reliance team give that sort of
caricatured exposition of your slaves
yeah it's
what is this tenderness
that's uh that's one of the most
incendiary moments in emerson that's
completely infuriating to a lot of
readers and uh
it's part of his commitment to um
talking about um
what he calls my slaves or in that
passage my poor are they my poor
what he means by that i think and i
agree with richard poirier who wrote
about it that um
when he says my poor he means people who
who are spiritually poor impoverished
and in need of what he's talking about
but he wants us in our
irritation with him at that passage he
wants us to start parsing these
distinctions
great
in
a professionalized institutionalized
academic
philosophy
taking seriously that maximum
you mean
does it boil down to making the move
from the academy to quote life
which is it which is a
is the problematic dichotomy that
nietzsche leaves us with
a philosopher who speaks to the general
public
well john dewey devote devoted he didn't
theorize it but he devoted his career to
the problems of men as he called them um
he was the great figure who
less tormented than william james um
carried on that
effort
um
for various reasons historical reasons
after dewey's death
philosophy became
very
professionalized turned inward
rorty
sought to emancipate himself from that
inward turn
but
and in some way tried to be a dewey for
his age and in some ways
succeeded but
the the audience had already shrunk it
he never had the the the scale of an
audience that james or a dewey had
i mean so in other words it's a it's a
problem that doesn't just be it's not
just about a thinker seeking a larger
audience it's it's also a sociological
cultural
condition that impedes that
i really possibility your example about
how you felt like your bookbind
unknowingly
was the occasion for your projects and
i've appreciated something like that
i've ever
but how do we
how do we understand
what are the fruitful
passions
that we allowed to do
to go on without our knowing and those
ones that might be unhealthy like surely
there's maybe there's not a difference
between such an act like that
or behavior like that and
hoarding
you know
because you weren't reading them enough
of them
but
i just wonder
yeah i'm sort of taking a benign example
my own example but you're right it's
interesting to think of it
i
mean for me i'm sure many others but
the healthiness of that
and then on the other hand
somebody who who's collected all these
things or just
allowed that to go on and any
indications nothing
well or you could just generalize that
neurotic behavior is not is is behaving
without knowing why right you're the
repetition compulsion of
of doing the same destructive thing
so it's just a different part of the
continuum
yeah that's correct
or you could just you could say it leads
to a great library that
maybe one day you will stop and start to
enjoy rather than compulsively buy i
mean
you don't have to consign it to a way a
wasted act or a futility
your relation to the books could change
over time
i don't
no that's a fascinating question
maybe one more is anyone
else's question
yeah go ahead
no no i i read her uh
novel on novalis the blue flower amazing
thank you